the identity of Anakin Skywalker's
father has been a point of contention
ever since it was first brought up in
the Phantom Menace now however we have a
piece of information that might shed
some new light on the true identity of
Darth Vader's deadbeat dad the major
selling point of the prequel trilogy of
the Phantom Menace attack of the clones
and Revenge of the Sith was that we'd be
able to see Anakin Skywalker's origins
learning more about who one of cinema's
greatest villains was before his fall
from grace in practice well we didn't
get a whole lot that we didn't already
know he used to be a Jedi then he went
bad and telling audiences that took six
hours and 345 million dollars there was
however one Death Star sized
truth bomb hiding in Episode one and
none of us were really prepared for it
when Anakin's mom Shmi Skywalker is
asked about who his father is
she simply explains that there wasn't
one instead she just woke up one morning
to find that she was pregnant the
religious overtones at play here are
pretty obvious a virgin birth --fill
told in prophecy heralding the arrival
of one who will bring balance to the
world they're also a bit on the nose
even for Star Wars a series where the
guy who's really good at piloting
spaceships is named Skywalker the guy
who doesn't want to join up with the
Rebel Alliance is named
Solo and the first hope for the light
side of the force to come along in years
is named Ray these movies have never
exactly been subtle but giving us a
messianic figure via virgin birth is on
a whole different level except of course
that there's a twist to it
rather than becoming the savior that the
Jedi have been waiting for
Anakin grows up to put down a bunch of
children with a lightsaber get rebuilt
as a cyborg and then commit full-on
genocide by blowing up entire planets
not exactly what any parents would hope
for their child unless one of them
happen to be a tyrannical overlord
devoted to death and corruption that is
but we'll get to that in a bit rather
than letting its biblical overtones
stand on their own episode one did
provide a further explanation for
Anakin's conception
although fans weren't exactly thrilled
with it up until that point the force
had always been portrayed as being
essentially well magic it was a
metaphysical presence that ran through
all living things and United the galaxy
as one then it turned out that it was
actually just a bunch of tiny bug
that lived in your blood episode one
introduced the concept of midi-chlorians
microscopic organisms found in the
bloodstream forming a symbiotic
relationship that allows their hosts to
connect with and well use the force the
more midi-chlorians you have floating
around your circulatory system the more
raw power you have when it comes to the
force it's essentially a plot device
allowing for a quick explanation of why
qui-gon jinn and obi-wan Kenobi are so
convinced that Anakin is a big deal
his midi-chlorian count is over 20,000
which is even more than Yoda's
unfortunately the implication here is
that a bunch of tiny midi-chlorians got
together and decided they should just go
ahead and make a baby inside some woman
who had zero knowledge that this was
happening let alone why that is at the
bare minimum pretty weird if nothing
else Luke Skywalker's grandfather being
a collection of sentient microbes that
construct babies as a hobby is gonna
make things pretty weird when the whole
family gets together on life day did you
ever hear the tragedy of Darth Plagueis
the wise we thought not it's not a story
that Jedi would tell you it is however
the subject of one of the best scenes in
Star Wars Episode three Revenge of the
Sith while watching a space opera
Chancellor Palpatine soon to claim
unlimited power as the Emperor tells
Anakin about a Sith Lord named Darth
Plagueis whose mastery of the dark side
of the force was so complete that he
could not only stop people from dying
but also create life by manipulating
midi-chlorians so that makes perfect
sense as Palpatine tells both Anakin and
the audience Plagueis passed down his
unnatural knowledge to his apprentice
who then killed him in his sleep this is
the tale that leads Anakin who not too
long ago wasn't able to save his mother
from death to study the dark side and
ultimately become Palpatine's apprentice
what Palpatine doesn't tell us although
it is heavily implied in the original
scene given the subject matter is that
Plagueis appearance was in fact darth
sidious perhaps better known as Emperor
Palpatine himself to find that out for
sure you have to dig deep into the
rebooted Star Wars Canon and keep up
with the novels and comics if you did
then you might already understand that
there was a deeper meaning to
Sidious telling Anakin about the
knowledge of how to manipulate
midi-chlorians to create life that all
brings us to the release of Marvel's
Star Wars Darth Vader number 25
it's the final issue of the series the
second and almost certainly not the last
Darth Vader comic Marvel has published
since Disney acquired the property back
in 2012 and the final chapter of a
storyline set on the planet Mustafar if
the name sounds familiar it's not just
because it reminds you of the tragic
patriarch of a certain animated Disney
flick it's because this fiery world is
where Anakin Skywalker died and where
Darth Vader was truly born it was the
planet we saw at the end of Revenge of
the Sith where obi-wan chopped off
Anakin's limbs and left him to die and
where Darth Vader's ominous castle was
seen in rogue one the comic fills in the
gaps between those two events and
Vader's return to Mustafar in the
construction of the castle alongside a
forgotten Sith Lord called Mahmoud in
keeping with Vader's obsession with
mastering death mom and himself has
managed to persist beyond the grave
existing as a spirit that could possess
anyone who donned the helmet that he'd
worn in life to make a long story short
Star Wars Darth Vader number 24 sees mom
and betray Vader and used the power of
the castle basically a giant magic key
to resurrect his body yep that's right
you've literally uses the Force to
recreate life just as Sidious told
Anakin all those years before needless
to say since we know that Vader
continues to exist in the Star Wars
universe and most moviegoers have never
heard of mom in Vader defeats the
traitorous spirit and uses the portal
for his own ends Darth Vader number 25
sees the Sith Lord tapping into the dark
side in a way that we've never really
seen before his soul leaves his body and
merges with the darkside itself the
visual is both striking and clear this
is Vader as he is within the armor a
creature sustained entirely by the dark
side with whatever good remains in him
hidden far beneath the massive anger and
fear as Vader journeys through the
strange hallucinatory terrain beyond the
portal he's shown key moments from his
past
complete with disjointed dialogue lifted
from the films though the original
spoken dialogue like that instance in
Episode one where Anakin asks Padme if
she was an angel sounded innocent in
their pre
context here they read straight-up
sinister we see these moments as they
happened in the films and then we get
one that seems new a memory that Vader
himself couldn't possibly have which
must instead be something that he's
learned from his communion with the dark
side
the image is of Shmi Skywalker pregnant
at first she's alone accompanied by the
line she spoke to fly gone back in
Episode one quote there was no father
then as Vader watches the spectral image
of Darth Sidious appears behind her
accompanied by the word unnatural the
exact word that Sidious used to describe
Darth Plagueis life creating techniques
in Episode three the message here is far
more clear than the implication back in
that scene at the space opera Sidious
himself had a hand in Anakin's creation
and was manipulating his life to bring
down the Republic long before qui-gon
obi-wan and Padme encountered him on
Tatooine of course like a lot of things
in Star Wars not everything Vader sees
during a surreal trip through the dark
side is meant to be taken literally like
Luke Skywalker's vision in the cave on
Dagobah there's plenty of it that's
meant to be shrouded in metaphor there
is for instance a scene where Vader's
soul has to fight its way past an army
of Jedi who were killed during Palpatine
schoo which is less about their ghosts
actually showing up for the Jedi
equivalent of revenge and more about
Vader metaphorically killing the person
he was before his fall the kylo Ren
quote that echoes backward through time
to accompany this moment let the past
die kill it if you have to tells us as
much there is another scene where this
becomes very important though and it's
accompanied by what is unquestionably
Vader's most famous piece of dialogue
quote I am your father that in itself is
a prophetic glimpse of the future this
story takes place long before Vader will
utter those fateful words to Luke
Skywalker in Cloud City but it's also
connected to the past the phrase is
positioned on the page so that it's
suspended between images of Palpatine
and obi-wan Anakin's two father figures
each of them guided Anakin as their
apprentice and ultimately each of them
will fail him in their own way
in the vision Palpatine and obi-wan face
off in the fight they never had in the
movies with Palpatine winning then Vader
strikes the Emperor down himself to
continue on his
jurnee the idea of these two men as
father figures plays into the Star Wars
saga as prominent themes but that scene
in particular echoes what we see from
Luke's vision and agava in that film
Luke strikes down the character that we
will eventually learn is his father only
to discover his own face beneath Vader's
mask here in the comic Vader kills
Palpatine with a shower of Force
Lightning which foreshadows their final
conflict in Return of the Jedi and
recontextualizes what we see there just
like an empire
Vader's true face is revealed but he
bears very little resemblance to Luke
instead his face pale and ruined from
years of embracing the dark side looks a
lot more like Palpatine's in the end
we're left with the question of what all
this means for the future of Star Wars
on one level this is just another entry
in the sagas long line of Sons dealing
with the legacy that was passed down by
their fathers matching right up with
Luke and Vader or kylo Ren and Han Solo
it's a recurring theme and given that
Palpatine plunged to his death back in
1983 it doesn't seem likely that it'll
be anything more than just another
branch on the complicated tangle that is
the Skywalker family tree cousins
roommate or at least it wouldn't seem
likely if we were talking about this way
back when but since the release of the
trailer for episode 9 the rise of
Skywalker we've all heard the familiar
sinister echo of Palpatine's laughs plus
we already know that ian McDermid who
played Palpatine in Return of the Jedi
in the prequel trilogy is set to make an
appearance in the film nobody saw that
coming but we deal as you know install
was they're very good at dealing in
unexpected moments the whole time
considering the timing of the issue and
the fact that it's big reveal came after
these elements were already in place it
seems likely that it's going to come up
in some form when episode 9 hits
theaters if nothing else we're going to
be seeing Darth Sidious knowing for the
first time that he's much more tied into
the Skywalker family than we thought
whether that's in the form of flashbacks
a first darkside force ghost or even a
shocking return from a pretty definitive
death it's bound
of an impact check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite films are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]